the accumulation of the passports is
based on
obviously how well you're playing but
also how much you're playing and which
type of games that you're playing across
different devices across games
and
again it's a nice incentive because you
can play play play and play and then
earn the ballpoint and then you can
redeem it for you what you love to do
best
uh so every game has its own choice uh
either they will
buy some
gift card
and order something of that or buy some
new game because they want to try it out
so we are giving them basically the
freedom to try out new things
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by home adventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with ctek
hello hello and welcome to 20 minute
leaders let's talk about gaming with eli
de beer the ceo and co-founder of
buff.game an israeli-based company that
completed its ipo in the 12v stock
exchange during august of 2021
buff have developed a loyalty program
for video gamers it's a fast-growing
technology platform eli is a father of
three and is 44 years old
eli de beer welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you so much for joining me how are
you and thank you for having me i'm
located in my office in eurea israel
uh doing very well
beautiful well thank you very much for
coming and joining me for these 20
minutes talking about buff and gaming
metaverse nfts and all the you know the
buzzwords that we love talking about
today i personally am so excited about
this world
and uh and i'm mind blown every morning
looking at the headlines and what new
advancements are being made and you know
looking at gaming but also and loyalty
programs and monetization and community
building i mean all those things that
are just evolving and it almost feels
like we're creating the rules from
scratch every day and and really there
it's a playground where we can do so
many things so eli tell me a little bit
about yourself and you know a little bit
about
why you're in gaming
uh
so my name is eli i'm 44 years old
married plus three kids
and i love video games
when i started it was like a long time
ago love to play uh
video games when it was still early i
still love playing it now
now i'm playing it with my kids actually
and it's really really cool they're now
even better than me
uh and i believe that um
this is the next version of
entertainment if when i was a kid i used
to be a gig playing some video games and
people were playing soccer outside
after that
kids watched a lot of tv
now everyone loves playing games so i
think it's like the future of
entertainment
and my kids coming back from school and
saying okay i'm going to meet my friends
now
and he's meeting them
while gaming and basically is meeting
them online playing volarant fortnite
talking to them discord everything is
mixed and this is his friends this is
how he spent his time i think this is
the evolution of entertainment
so by the way on starting on a very
theoretical level you know watching your
kids coming home and playing games you
know there's you know the counter
argument that you know but half of
society i think has
you know is the fact that you know the
relationships that we're building
through the metaverse and through you
know social gaming you know they're not
a direct replacement to the in-person
relationships and what is the next
generation of relationships going to
look like how do you see this world
so one i i guess i'm one of the only
parents that actually motivate my kids
to play games which is
not telling them stop playing all day
long
and
i i think it's an evolution
and we will reach some uh
some point when it will be a hybrid yes
kids have to to play outside and
and do some sport and i'm really
motivating them and they're doing like
their athletics and running and going
outside
but for them it's exciting they're
learning new skills and new uh
experiences and i think it's it's
definitely the way it's going to be
and the kids love doing it
it really gives them a motivation in so
many ways
they learn how to speak english just by
playing with
with kids their age from all over the
world and i found out that the kids know
how to really speak english and not just
their vocabulary that they learn in
school this is how they learn to
communicate
so
and once they're not playing they're
watching a lot of youtube and watch what
other users are doing so it's
i guess it's evolving uh i think it's
always going to be some kind of
balancing point
and kids the parents and need to to
guide them the right way but i think
they can learn a lot from it and i think
that the world is going to a place where
they can
educate themselves and learn and
progress
right so to set the stage for buff and
what you're doing you know with with
games and loyalty programs
how has gaming evolved over the last you
know
few decades to reach the point where
now we're talking about communities and
marketplaces and and loyalty programs
within games with buff
so
as it became more popular and a lot of
things
got with one content obviously once
there's a great content it attracts
gamers
so if there was like small games and
people and it was not really accessible
with uh obviously desktop but then
consoles mobile everything is coming
people are
i used to play games like a quarter or
third of the world population
are playing games at the moment everyone
are playing games okay if you're driving
somewhere if you're going on subway or
if you are at home it doesn't matter
it's part of your ongoing life
and the content
the free to play or the framing model
becoming more and more popular so
everyone are getting getting exposed to
great content and you have a reach to an
amazing amazing uh
entertainment and experiences so
everyone can can evaluate it and you can
travel really easy you don't need to pay
a lot of money to buy some title and i
can just try it out
it's much more a community now because
they're playing fortnite with a hundred
users from all over the world you don't
know them it's the only time you will
ever meet them
uh
so it's really cool and now metaphors
you know it's a really bad water thing
but it will it will get there and if
ariana grande is doing a live show in
fortnight and millions of users
from all over the world including me and
my kid are watching it live because it's
exciting it's cool
and you're watching a real artist on the
like video game everything is interwined
it's it's exciting
and i think this is where buff comes
into play because
i spend a lot of time myself
and my kid and everyone playing games so
i think some kind of flawed
a rewards and loyalty programs coming
into play and basically taking the user
the gamer into all of his experiences
makes a lot of sense because
personally and many of gamers like to
play different games like play cs go and
then they will play valorant and then
we'll play epic legend and you're
traveling again the content is the king
and you're moving between content
and everything is siloed because every
game student which are doing ram studios
everything is stuck over there and then
you're moving because this is the way it
is you're going into the new trend and
games like to try new things out and
everything's stuck
and for me i'm spending a lot of time
some kind of players that really reward
me for what i'm doing and based on my
real achievements makes a lot of sense
uh
for me as a gamer and this is where
basically the idea came to life
and then basically i spend time on
something so why not
earn something while i'm doing it anyway
and the entire concept was okay i'm
playing anyway why not do something
along the way and uh
at the moment gamers can come enjoy play
what they are doing anyway play ball
around playing epics legend play rocket
league and buff points simply by playing
in the better they will play the more
the more they will earn based on their
in-game achievement
and then with the points that they've
earned they can buy in-game currency
like rp or vlogs
buy new games get order domino's pizza
to their own or buy a keyboard makes a
lot of sense
uh and again um my vision
it should
uh be alert on top of all my gaming
activities and we've just launched a
card a debit card in the u.s cooperation
with visa basically allow gamers also to
get rewarded on their uh offline
basically uh expenses
like star alliance as united explorer
card which makes a lot of sense for
as a gamer
so i think everything
goes well hand in hand
so what it i i hear from you is that you
know there's a distance in the gaming
world that on one hand it feeds off of
this idea of continuity storyline
you gain experience there's so many you
know gamification coming from games they
say yeah you progress and you become
emotionally attached to what you're
doing but at the same time gamers you
know we like to enjoy to enjoy several
games and one day we want to play this
the other day we want to play that but
but then we're confronted with the
siloed issue that once we transfer to
the new game everything we did yesterday
is not there and so that that's fighting
and so buff is sort of bridging these
things together but then also bridging
platform basically combining between the
digital and offline
uh
and becoming the companion app platform
for gamers basically for all the gaming
activities
so two two large questions that that
hopefully will guide us for the next
short while
how do the
you know studios interact with us
because studio sometimes you know you
have completely different companies
playing different games and you as the
third party are cut you know you're
coming together and trying to bridge
them together
and then the second question is sort of
if how does the economics of all this
work in terms of bringing the in-game
experience to the offline and what are
the incentives for
the outside companies to come in and
like visa or like dominoes to come and
take part in this new marketplace that
you're creating
so great question uh basically we're a
layer that sits on top of the games
we're able to collect data we are
partly doing it ourselves partly with
overwolf an israeli-based company which
a great company great guys that helped
us basically to provide us some of the
data
and the main challenges as you mentioned
is to take different games with
completely different game economics and
game modes
and put it all together and rocket
league is very much different than
league of legends completely different
uh time achievements and all the game
students are doing changes all the time
and basically buffers developers
self-rendering algorithms that able to
one monitor all the in-game event
and
and to
give a smart reward
which will really motivate gamers and
make them a better gamer in the end
because it will be
based on the actual uh achievements so
if someone is doing a
a triple kill
to simplify you will get more someone
doing a double kill okay but it's much
more complex complex and need to
normalize between different games and
it's a complex economy
and putting it all together basically on
the accumulation of the passports is
based on
obviously how well you're playing but
also how much you're playing and which
type of games you're playing
across different devices across games
and
again it's a nice incentive because you
can play play play and play and then
earn the ballpoint and then you can
redeem it for you what you love to do
best
uh so every gamer has its own choice uh
either they will
buy some
gift card
and order something of that or buy some
new game because they want to try it out
so we are giving them basically the
freedom to try out new things
and if you're connected to the offline
world basically we're saying okay you're
spending uh
spending outside
why not and again for gamers the core
audience is like 18 to 34.
average gamer in the us is around 31 32
years old
this is a
the more interesting that gamers this is
what i like love to do so they can spend
in walmart or starbucks using a card and
then redeem it for something they love
to do as gamers and again they can buy a
new gaming set or they can just order a
pizza everything goes
right and to form these partnerships
whether in the offline or the
or the gaming world is this trivial for
the parties that you're talking to are
you coming to them and they're saying
yeah obviously we want to take part in
this you know in in this new world we
understand this or is this something
that you know is taking time for their
mind to wrap around
a simple question it depends the simple
answer depends depends on who we're
talking to and how we formalize the
relationship uh
so we're talking from team to uh to
brands and uh
for some of them it makes a lot of sense
how to collaborate and how to do new
things and create things
we are doing some direct campaigns for
uh for brands we did one the alienware
games the 2021 basically we did an
entire activation for gamers on our
community
that they had to compete on four
different games and basically earned
like cool rewards
everything was done on the onboard
platform for the community so they got
some cool rewards the brand got an
amazing exposure to the core gamers and
not just some
banner or some video because they had to
engage with the actual brand so it makes
a lot of sense
for all parties and
my view is if the gamer or the end users
will be happy
then all the stakes holder will will be
happy with that as well
give me few of your predictions for
gaming you know in the next few years
well where are we positioned to go from
here and i know it's such a volatile
question but
there's so much variability as to what
could happen but but where in your mind
do you think we're headed as a society
and you know the average person gamer
so
again
the changes that the gaming is going
through it's rapid
and revenue
it overpass the
movies
movie and music industry combined
it's growing really fast
uh esport as an example a few years ago
no one understood what is it all about
only small gigs try to compete with each
other and becoming a league
and there are dozens of teams and you
can
view almost any college in the in
in the us they have an espo team
okay it's a new uh industry that came to
life and people are watching it and
millions of dollars of privacy so esport
i think it's going to be a a huge thing
uh going forward
the matter versus it's a big password at
the moment uh but i think it will go
into into shape and i realized that
rather than fortnite was a great example
going forward and how to combine between
the offline and online and i think that
buff is doing as well becoming
bringing the community and what users
are doing in the offering world with
online world makes a lot of sense
and it is it's again i think it's it's a
huge password at the moment it's kind of
a hype and everyone are talking about it
it makes a lot of sense
to many of the stakeholders but it
still has big problems from regulation
to
end users
it's not a lot of friction with us
experience so i think it will
get to a point which will be like really
seamless for the users
um
but it i think it will take some time
definitely super exciting uh
like vertical
will go through
incredible
which part of this whole puzzle
are you most thrilled about and excited
about and i'm sure that you're thrilled
and excited about a lot because you're
motivating your kids to play games and
that is and not ordinary statement but
um but it's fascinating so where you
know what is it really thrilling you
here
so
i think it's only combined together
because
there's no like one single thing and
these four teams are talking about
doing an nft
and talking about how to do a metaverse
everything into wide and go there
everything goes together and building
the community together
and giving the users extra viruses i
think it will be combined in some way
and
you can't touch the one without the
other
uh so it's not going to be okay one big
title uh world of warcraft that's it
everyone are playing that so everything
and you need
a community around it and then you have
an esport team because they are playing
it and everything is connected to each
other and if you even if you take roblox
in the example they did a nice campaign
with chipotle which is
everything and you can play a roblox
game and then go to chipotle and buy
like a tacos or whatever so everything
is goes hand in hand
right
now if you're looking at this you know i
think the theme of this whole
conversation
we can pretty much summarize it with the
world with the word you know rapid
change you know the whole thing is we're
talking about how it's quickly changing
and we have to con constantly adapt and
we have generational gaps and i think
that one of the most interesting things
here is that you know in traditional
economics and traditional markets we see
a movement and you know we as consumers
we sort of understand how to eat it up
and absorb it and then adapt but here we
have a new movement which is so
unnatural for some age groups and some
cultures that just wrapping their man
and we're seeing you know the industry
is booming like you're mentioning that i
didn't i had no idea that gaming is
larger than the movies and music
combined that's incredible to me
and so i think that we're in a really
interesting inflection point with this
with where we're going
with this change how do you keep up
how do you go about continuing to be a
leader
both of the company but also a thought
leader in a space that is involving so
quickly
so
focus on the end user on the gamer
if it will make sense for them and
simplify the experience for them it will
make it make a lot of sense
again looking at
as an example on the iphone
first time you touch an iphone
understood exactly what you had to do
and if we
give value to our users and value is not
just rewarding them but the entire
experience and for them to understand
and experience what we want them to
experience and make sense for them on
their first time using experience and
going forward
and everything will be centered around
the users it will make a lot of sense
for everyone
right and for you personally underst
continuing to
be on top of the market and understand
the market how do you go about doing
that
so exploring every new trend and we love
to do i love to do experience moving
really fast trying new things out we
have a really large uh
user base we can try and experiment for
real and see how users can react to it
we love to test it out
a lot of everything is data driven so
testing things see how the real users
are interacting with it and then you can
get a real sense of what's going on so
you don't need the
vast market research it's just put on a
new feature something new test it out
and see how users interact with it
collect the data and move fast together
with that
eli
thank you very very much for spending
these 20 minutes with me and sharing
with me both your insights and your
perception on this world and buff and it
is so crazy and cool at the same time
and it was just an honor to have you
here so thank you and and best of luck
with buff and i can't wait to to use the
loyalty program myself and i i haven't
shared this with many people yet but
i've gotten so much into gaming and i
now finally at 25 understand why you
know what's this hype that i've been
hearing about for the last seven years
from all my friends and nieces and
everything so it's pretty crazy
thank you for giving me the time and
thank you
thank you take care bye